[Musique]
tu connais le coin je cherche une porte
il a parlé d'une porte
c'est pas possible
qu'est-ce que tu fais bien fermer cette
porte non
quand les émotions disparaissent dans
les endroits abandonnés les portes
s'ouvrent et le vert s'il faut file
c'est comme ça que les catastrophes
arrivent je t'aime bien et toi tu es
dans mes pattes
[Musique]
tu ne peux pas venir avec moi tu vas me
gêner dans cet état tu peux rien faire
tu es une chaise
tu cherches un chat tu es venu de Kyushu
pour ça
dans pas longtemps il y a plein de gens
qui vont mourir
[Musique]
la porte
je n'y arriverai pas tout seul
c'est un tout raté est-ce que je me
trompe je ne fais
oublier tout ce que tu as pu voir je ne
veux pas vivre dans un monde sans
sauteur
comment est-ce que je pourrais oublier
je reviendrai pour te sauver c'est
promis
il devrait penser un peu plus à lui j'ai
l'impression que tu dois accomplir
quelque chose de très important je
voulais rester
[Musique]
j'y vais